so it was in the news that there's a
50-pound note coming out with alan
turing on it now alan turing has been
featured from time to time on our our
channel and rightly so
dave's done some fabulous videos on all
the work that he and a lot of others
were doing at bletchley park
you know cracking enigma and it got me
thinking
you know now that we're in the 21st
century and i've got a laptop that's
much more powerful than all the cheering
bombs put together
how easy is it to break enigma like
today right so i thought let's code up
and find out the first thing i should
say is they've done some really
interesting videos on the history of
enigma
and uh do go and watch those right and
it'll give you an idea for sort of
things they were doing to try and break
enigma back during the 40s
not to trivialize it but it's really
difficult isn't it it's really really
difficult right you know
this isn't something one does by hand
right not quickly um
the enigma machine is not a stupid idea
right it's well designed
the only thing that we've got now is
much much more processing power
and so things that we couldn't possibly
brute force back then maybe we can start
to begin to brute force now right and
that's what we're looking at today
so let's look very briefly at what the
knitting machine is and then we'll have
a go at actually breaking one and see
whether it holds up
if you recall it has some lights on some
letters and it has this is my technical
description
has some buttons that you press keys are
they cool sometimes so you press an a
right you press an a
and it goes into the machine and it goes
through something called a plug board
and the plug board will swap it so this
is the plug board here
now plugs just swap certain letters in
pairs so maybe this a
comes out as a an f right or something
like that
then this goes into the first rotor
and so that maybe comes out as a q or
something like that so you know it sort
of just
wiggles around in here and then this
comes in
this comes out as maybe you know a p i'm
making this up
and then this goes into the next rotor
to stick to three rotary enigmas for
today hey
uh comes out as a sort of an s and then
it goes through something called a
reflector so this is getting quite
complicated but this is all mechanical
right these rotors literally physically
turn around and they just have wires
soldered from one end to the other
that connect up so the reflector just
bounces s goes to something else i can't
remember which led
is and then it goes back through this
like this and then it comes around
through the plug board again so maybe
that d
goes to i mean a's over here that was
that was a bit silly of me wasn't it
um over here
for the purposes of this it's all
absolutely fine and this comes out as
a zed right so in my in in my weird
botched enigma diagram the a went in and
it came out as a zed it was encrypted as
a zed
now what's hard about this problem well
you can take these
rotors out right each rotor has
different wiring there's usually five or
eight rotors to choose from and you can
put them in any position you like
the next one is that every time you
press a letter one of the rotors rotates
and sometimes
it rotates the next rotors along and
that means that this mapping this
transformation
changes every time you press a character
so you press a
it's not going to do the same thing
again no actually if you press a
the rotor first turns and then lights up
a letter right so
it's not going to do the same again if
you press aaaa the only thing you're
guaranteed due to one of the quirks of
enigma is you won't get any a's back but
you'll get a lot of random letters
back during the war they solved this by
trying to find
possible rotor configurations that
definitely couldn't work or could work
based on some guest
playing text so maybe they had this idea
that
the first part of the message contained
the word weather report
and so if they put that in and they then
they could find all the encryptions that
couldn't possibly have come out as
weather report and so on
and they could start to narrow down what
their options were now
that's called a known plane text attack
but during the war if they hadn't known
the plaintext they wouldn't be able to
crack enigma they didn't have the brute
force power to do it
nowadays we have pretty fast laptops
right and you know beyond my laptop
other computers are even faster than
that would you believe
so theoretically we could start to try
out some of these combinations even if
we didn't know any plain text
what we're going to be looking at at
least to begin with is a
ciphertext text only attack that's an
attack where we've only got the cipher
text we don't have any idea what the
plain text is
and we want to see if we can guess what
some of these settings would be
there's a few interesting weaknesses of
enigma
that make it a little bit practical to
brute force but not actually as much as
you think
we talk a lot about how a letter doesn't
encrypt ever to itself
and that's quite relevant for plain text
attacks known plain text because you can
then work out where plaintext definitely
can't or could be
we're not doing that today so i'm less
worried about that particular property
of enigma
more interesting to me is the fact that
if you get some of the settings right
like you get this rotor correct but
these two wrong
that will often be better at decrypting
than if you get them all wrong
right so as we start to move slowly
towards a solution
we get a little hint that maybe this
ciphertext isn't quite as good as it was
and we can start measuring it so really
what we need to do is find some way of
putting some some ciphertext into an
enigma machine with some configuration
and then reading the output and saying
is that a plausible sentence or not
right and preferably we'd like to do it
really really quickly because otherwise
this could take a long time
so we're not going to be doing any deep
learning can't be bored with that um
we're going to use very simple
statistical properties of text
to try and measure whether one sentence
is better as english than another
sentence right and there's a few of
these and i've implemented all of them
because i thought well let's just test
them out right
so the first one is something called
index of coincidence
so let's suppose you have a cipher text
so for example
oh here it is i'm just looking at random
text right
so yeah okay i'm just going to copy some
random cipher text from here right so
why i can't just randomize my own soft
text i don't know but i feel more
comfortable copying it than i do just
thinking up clever interesting letters
on my own
said well so there's no number files on
the fact that i don't pick as random as
i think and stuff like that
yeah so you then do s e uh
b h w this is some actual cipher text
that we'll be breaking later
does it honestly start with zeus as in
conrad's use yeah
the reality of random yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
you see all kinds of words in the random
ciphertext and they mean absolutely
nothing because it hasn't been decrypted
yet
uh oh g yeah well exactly
e u so let's suppose we have some type
of text like this
we guess some rotor settings and we put
it through our enig machine
enigma machine and that will decrypt it
right now it will probably decrypt it
incorrectly
but where we accidentally stumble upon
the right plugs
or we stumble upon the right rotor
configuration even for a briefly
we'll find that this decryption is
slightly better than
completely random right because actually
mostly
this is completely random right yes we
have this stipulation that
letters can't turn into themselves but
generally speaking it looks completely
random so this is what we get out so h
f my writing is bad today v
v f l i n
g now the interesting thing about this
is i mean it's complete nonsense right
let's let's
i'm not cracking any words on this but i
do recognize ing
now ing is a fairly common trigram or
set of three characters in the english
language right
now that doesn't necessarily mean this
is correct but it's slightly more
english should we say than this one
right so if we were measuring some
amount of how
english is this sentence how you know
then it's a little bit closer than this
so maybe one of our rotors is in the
right position and the others are wrong
right or our rotor's in the correct
position but our plugs are wrong or
something like this
right and the idea is that we slowly
go through different configurations of
our enigma machine
i say slowly as fast as we can right and
we measure
statistical properties of these output
sentences to find the ones that clo
most closely resemble correct decrypted
text right and we can do this without
looking at them
we don't have to look at them and say
well that's a real word we just
measure statistical properties so what
are some of these statistical properties
well
the first one is called the index of
coincidence or i o
c this is the probability that when you
pick two letters at random
they'll be the same so for example if we
randomly pick p and then we randomly
pick p that's versus the same if we pick
p
and then l they're not the same you know
we won't write the formula the form is
not that complicated
so but what you have to do is go through
and count count every single
character and how many of each one there
are you produce a histogram and then you
can calculate the index of coincidence
based on this now for random text that
is text that's been put through the
machine are not decrypted
the index of coincidence is usually
something like 0.038
right which is basically everything's
evenly distributed there's nothing
interesting going on there at all
but for decrypted english text we
usually get
a higher index of questions about 0.067
and i think it's something like 0.072
for german text one way of looking at it
is it measures the
the the fact that some characters have
more higher probabilities than others if
everything's equally likely
you get something like this if some
characters are quite common and so they
tend to come up in pairs
it starts to look a little bit higher
right it never goes higher than this
so well not really what we can do is we
can
work through our rotors different rotors
different positions different settings
and we can calculate our index of
coincidence and we take the best scoring
texts right so where our output has a
higher index equations we think maybe
we've got the rotor settings correct
right and that's basically how it works
there's been a number file right where
they actually got to use the enigma
machine and i'm super jealous
they talked about the number of
different combinations so it's all very
well saying okay we'll just go through
all the rotor settings
and work out you know what the best one
is right
maybe if i have you know a super super
super computer um
but actually enigma has a nifty weakness
in this sense right
which is that if you get some of the
settings correct
this will improve right if i get the
voter positions correct even though the
rotors are in slightly wrong position
the result will be better than if i've
got the wrong rotors in place
right if i get one of the plug board
settings right
the results would be better than if i
got none of the plug board settings
right because basically
fewer characters will be incorrect right
subtly
so you've got three out of let's say
five rotors or eight rotors so that's
physically
the three that happen to be in the
machine at the time yeah and you've got
their different positions right so if
for today we just talk about five rotors
just because i've always been sitting
here a little bit longer
then we've got 60 possible positions one
we've got to choose three out of five
and then they can all go in any slot
you don't tend to have the same motor
twice right because i mean they didn't
have those
duplicates of rotors yeah one set of
them yeah yeah
yeah yeah um so we've got that
then for each of these we have a start
position from from uh 1 to 26 which is
you know
what letter is showing on the top right
basically how how rotated it is
so you've got the start position or the
indicator setting so there's you know
times let's say
26 of those times by three of the
different motors right
then you've got the ring setting now the
ring setting is essentially
rotating the internals of the rotor
right
now actually if you if we ignore the
notch for a minute which i'll talk about
if you rotate the ring and you rotate
the the um
actual whole rotor they kind of cancel
each other out so
it's about the notch position really the
notch is when
the rotor turns it turns the next one
along and so
the combination of your start position
and your ring setting will mean where
your notch is and then when it turns
around so you've got the ring settings
right which is going to be 26 x
3 again then we've got the plug board
which as you know swaps random
characters and that's got something like
10 different pairs out of 13 possible
pairs that's 150 trillion
i think different combinations that's
you know out of reach of
my laptop um certainly when i'm doing
all these decryptions as well
and we're multiplied by all these things
right the number file goes into much
better detail on this
we're looking at five today because uh
again i don't want to be here all day
it does get harder to solve and we'll
talk about that so this is a lot of
combinations it's too many combinations
for me to go through
even with this nice little industrial
coincidence thing right even though when
i get this exactly right
i will just get the plain text out and
it will have a very nice illness
coincidence and i might be able to find
it
so what do we do well the weakness of
enigma is that
if we get some of these things right
even if the others are wrong
we get a little bit closer to the answer
usually so for example
if you get the correct three rotors in
the correct positions and you get their
start positions roughly correct
if your ring settings are wrong all
that'll do is mess around with the
notches
so you'll get bits of your plain text
correct and then bits of
cipher text and then bits of plain text
and you get these kind of pockets of
valid characters
coming out of into the into the
decryption it will still score better on
ioc or any other metric
so that's what we're going to do and
this is the same with the plugs if we
get the
rotors and the start positions and the
ring settings correct
then we can start to guess plugs and
generally speaking if we guess one
correctly
the output would better and we can then
move towards a solution
there's a lot of possible variations but
the fact that we can deal with some of
them at a time
makes this practical right if we had to
brute force through all the different
variations it wouldn't be possible
that's the idea so i've written some
code to do this um
if you want to have a go i'll make my
code available but also there's a really
good online tool called crypto which
lets you do this in a visual way uh
we'll put a link to that in the
description
but i've written some pretty simple code
here i implemented an enigma machine
because it was fun
um and then i implemented a number of
different fitness functions
right which is how good is our
decryption in
index of questions is one right i also
um
maybe we can talk about some others
another time so you were kind enough to
send me some ciphertext i don't know
what it is
and it's been encrypted by some enigma
configuration with i think five plugs
the first thing i do
is i go through all the different rotor
configurations
and i find the one that has the highest
index of coincidence score when it
decrypts that message
so this is of five different rotors
each one tried in each position and at
each starting position so that's 26 for
each one
so that's quite a few combinations about
17 000 but 17 000 for a laptop
in 2021 not such a big deal right takes
somewhere around
10 seconds or something like that right
so you can see what it's doing now is
it's stepping through the different
rotors so one two three one two four
one two five and we've done about 10 or
15 configurations already
and for each of these it's going through
all the different starting positions but
we're not looking at ring settings and
we're not looking at plug board because
that will just multiply this
astronomically by the number of things
we have to do
so we're already on rota 3 in the
left-hand side we're keeping going
this same thing works exactly the same
for eight rotors it doesn't really
change
anything it just takes slightly longer
and i'm a bit lazy
so i have actually coded up the other
motors as well
um interestingly enough some of the
later rotors have two notches on
right which is not it doesn't make any
difference in terms of the cracking
because um so that just means it turns
the next one twice as well yeah
yeah twice often yep um only really
affects
the first two rotors the last one
doesn't ever really turn that often and
it doesn't have any other
motor to turn so here what we've got is
we've got a list of the top performing
rotor configurations so 2
5 3 is the best performing rotor
configuration with start positions of 21
3 and 25
i'm using zero indexing right which is
not how you would normally do it in
enigma but it was easier for my array
indexing to do this
right and that has an index of
coincidence of 0.043 which is a lot
higher than 3
8. i say it's a lot higher it's a little
bit higher good enough
so that suggests to me i mean we
actually i listed the top 10 here
because sometimes you might not get the
one on the top one you might get the
next rotor configuration or something
like this
it's worth maybe if you were trying to
really actually pay attention to this
what you would do is maybe
start doing further attacks on the top
three rotor configurations
just to keep your options open so we're
gonna fix
at two five and three because you know
it saves time
right um so given
rotors two five three from left to right
and their starting positions
what we now can do is we can start to
brute force through the ring settings so
we can find the best possible ring
settings
right now this is almost instant because
there's now only
600 or so of those right um
we don't need to try the left-hand rotor
because it doesn't really rotate and so
we do that and it's already happened
and the best ring positions were 0 3 23
right now the zero we ignore because
it's not
the ring possessing remember affects
where the notch is and the left rotor
doesn't turn anything over
so it doesn't have any effect so given
that
this is the ciphertext we've got out
this was our original ciphertext
and this is our slightly better
ciphertext now it still looks like total
nonsense
right but it has a much higher index of
coincidence score than the original
which means in some sense it's less
random so if you look you might start to
see
groups of letters that might be a real
word they might not i don't know
right but some of the real letters are
going to come out here we might not be
able to see what they are
so given this we can finally start
addressing this really problematic plug
board situation remember there's far too
many plug ball combinations
to realistically just try them all but
again we have this wonderful benefit
that if we get one of the plugs correct
the result will probably be better than
if we got none of them right so what we
do
is we go through each of the first 300
and so
different possible plugs just one at a
time and we see which the best one is
right and then we fix it and we do the
next for the next one and that's two
plugs and then we do for next to the
next one and that's three plugs
right and so on and if we do that we
very quickly
come up with a few sets of plugs and our
ciphertext is starting to look a lot
better right so this is our ciphertext
here the first letter is a nonsense but
then is reposed to consider
the quest que consider the quest
can machines think ah see now i'm
starting to guess what this might be oh
i see what you've done here this is the
alan turing paper so some of the letters
are wrong right so it should be i
propose to consider
and it's j brapos to consider right
and we're nearly there but that's
because when we optimized the motor
configuration we fixed the rings at zero
zero zero
so it was never going to find the exact
correct thing so essentially the
turnover is slightly wrong everything's
slightly wrong
but it's still pretty good now if we go
back to our original question as to how
secure is enigma
the answer is not very secure right and
the reason is not because it's trivial
to break right this took me a little bit
of effort
and for short messages where these
fitness functions start to break down
because you don't have enough
information
they're actually actually very robust
right for a 50 character message
very very difficult to break using
something like an index of coincidence
because even if some of the letters
start to appear right there's not very
many of them
the index is just noise in the war they
limited or they they attempted to limit
messages to something like 200 250
characters
for this reason because index of
coincidence was already known right
and there's now more powerful metrics
like trigram scores and quadrants
which i've also implemented which often
work better particularly for the plug
board
and so if you have a short message
you don't get very much information on
the different frequencies of different
groups of letters and so there's really
no way to know what's going on at all
right and you get very lucky or you
don't
and most likely you don't right the
other issue is of course the number of
plugs i've only done five plugs here
so i've cheated a bit right for most
german messages were sent using 10 plugs
you're going to need 1200 to 1500
characters before
fitness functions are going to start to
give you something right if you know
what the playing text might be
this becomes much much easier right
because if you can fix
these characters have to be exactly this
your fitness function is much less noisy
right i know actually i've implemented
that as well and it just starts
breaking it no no like nobody's business
right so it is
crackable right if you know if you can
guess what plaintext is and of course
modern
cryptography assumes you know what the
plain text is right at least for some of
the message
for example whenever you send an http
message to a web server
the beginning bit always says http get
or something similar right
but there's a very known structure to
these things you can start to guess what
they would be
we can't assume that you wouldn't know
what any of the plaintext was
but even if we don't you can see that
these index of coincidence and trigram
scores and things
can start to tease out some information
um
so going back to the beginning
enigma is actually harder to crack than
i thought
right people always talk about how hard
it was to crack during the war and
that's absolutely fine
but you just kind of assume that now
it's 2021 laptops should be able to just
click
go for all the settings find yourself
the ciphertext doesn't really work that
way
right you have to try and stumble your
way towards it and often it doesn't work
and there's noise in the output and so
you have to try and work out whether
what you're seeing is actually
improvement or not and so on which i
think is quite interesting
modern ciphers don't have this problem
if you have a 128 bit as key
you can't brute force the first bit
because
different like the zero or one won't
give you any better
or worse playing text right it will just
be nonsense each time and that's true of
any amount
so you can't do like the first half of
the key and then the second half of the
key which is kind of what we're doing
here
so modern ciphers don't have this
problem
and so on we can't do a lot of
interesting things with this image after
just one set of convolutions
but we're getting there so this one is
starting to be transformed
some of them are noisier than others
paint associated with it showing
which was the proper setting with a at
the top an a against the dot of paint